chaque jour il avait un bon
[Musique]
je devais rond de décision
de quitter Syrie pour mes enfants pour
être
en sécurité
c'est au Québec que a trouvé sa terre
d'accueil en 2016 elle travaille dans
une banque en français qu'elle a appris
dès son arrivée au pays Dana bourré
sa famille a emprunté le chemin de
millions de réfugiés syriens celui d'une
vie plus paisible et prospère pendant
que tous les portes étaient fermées pour
les syriennes c'est Canada c'était la
seule
qu'elle est ouverte les portes pour nous
chérissent les souvenirs d'avant-géralep
et rêvent même de poursuivre des études
supérieures rimes comblée à une seule
exception près
sa jeune sœur nourritée derrière au
Liban coincé dans les limbes du système
québécois de parrainage
je ne peux pas travailler je peux pas
retourner dans mon pays et je ne peux
pas encore me rendre au Canada
maintenant ma vie est arrêtée je ne peux
rien faire j'ai l'impression d'être en
prison nous a fui sa ville natale Alep
en direction de gazienne Tepe en Turquie
jusqu'au tremblement de terre de février
dernier caïman les cours de sa vie
Fabienne
nous avons dormi dans la rue pendant
trois jours c'était très difficile et
cela a certainement affecté mon état
psychologique ma santé c'était horrible
c'est comme si je ressentais un séisme à
l'intérieur de moi tout le temps je
pouvais pas marcher je restais tout le
temps assise je pleurais constamment
fuit à nouveau pour éviter les camps de
réfugiés turques il traverse la
frontière libanaise clandestinement pour
s'installer à Beyrouth mais le Liban
multiplie les rafles pour déporter les
réfugiés syriens qui seraient entre 1 et
2 millions selon les estimations dans un
pays d'un peu plus de 5 millions
d'habitants
nous ne pouvons pas sortir de la maison
ou nous promener dans le pays je ne peux
pas parce que il y a des points de
contrôle de l'armée ou de la police et
s'il m'arrête ils vont certainement
m'expulser vers la Syrie
elle se cache en quasi permanence dans
cet appartement de peur d'être repérés
alors à cause de ça elle peut pas
travailler premièrement ça c'est la plus
importante pour être capable de vivre
là-bas
de la générosité de sa famille et de ses
parents au Québec depuis la fin février
on envoie à peu près 1200 dollars
canadiens par mois carole est exaspéré
le dossier de Nour n'a toujours pas été
examiné tout d'abord on avait déposé en
février 2022
un engagement formel apparaît nous et
son conjoint le ministère de
l'Immigration du Québec qui approuve les
demandes avant de les transmettre à
Ottawa accuse plus en retard c'est un
digne de des conventions internationales
on a aussi un devoir de d'humanité
envers les réfugiés et là à quoi ça
correspondent les citronniers des
dossiers de gens qui sont dans des
situations terribles
nous profite néanmoins de cette attente
interminable pour apprendre le français
toujours confiante qu'elle recevra
finalement l'appel du Québec
je souhaite que mon dossier de
parrainage aille de l'avant et que mes
papiers soient en règle pour que enfin
je puisse vivre travailler avoir des
enfants tout en étant proche de ma
famille au Canada on espère que Canada
elle peut nous donner notre droit de
réunir notre famille
ça c'est le plus important pour nous
[Musique]
leur vie en apparence paisible ne le
sera jamais complètement avec le spectre
de voir une sœur une tente déportée vers
une série toujours déchirée